good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday claude
is coming to us live from the studio
it's so
it's so heartwarming to see those toasty
palm leaves hey claude how are you doing
well what you're seeing is the toasty
palm leaves in front of me i'm seeing a
studio that hasn't been touched in
months there are packages
everywhere it's literally it's chaos
here that's why i had to come in we got
to go through some of these boxes um
anything good
yeah a mattress
more sewing down south pillows some
copies of my book
lots of skin care lots of different new
sponsors coming on so it's exciting but
before we get into today's show i have
four things to say that i actually wrote
down
wow
wow this better be good
the first thing is that i wanted to let
everyone know that if you're coming to
my shows this weekend on in boston on
saturday and sunday we will be having
spritz which is very exciting so come
thirsty
another spritz related announcement
is if you're a california resident we
are now being sold in bevmo locations
and total wine so i know a lot of the
locations have received the shipments
yet and you guys have already gone some
of them are still rolling out so just
call your local bevmo your local total
wines if you want to get spritz in store
which is very exciting that was two
three
do you remember how i was talking about
a couple weeks no like a week ago that i
caught up on rupaul's drag race and my
favorite queen was cornbread which
ultimately meant she was gonna go home
soon yes
i forgot to tell you that on last
friday's episode cornbread hurt her
ankle and went home so i literally
cursed her immediately
but it's pre-filmed so not really
and the fourth thing i have to say is i
have an enormous surprise for you
for me is it just for me is it for
everyone for you
well everyone can enjoy
oh my god i'm so excited what is it so
do you remember how i called you last
night and then you were like sorry i
just woke up i'll call you back and then
i said no never mind i forgot
yeah
well i didn't forget i realized the
thing i wanted to show you i wanted to
show you on air because it is a gift for
you
oh my god okay i'm ready so excited yeah
hi jackie this is carl from the real
housewives of salt lake city
claudia wanted me to tell you
good luck with your pregnancy and that
you're an amazing sister
she loves you so much and believes that
you will be a great mom to your baby boy
i have a truck for you that i think you
will thoroughly enjoy here's a joke
at the wedding there are three rings
there's the engagement ring the wedding
ring
and the suffering
up you i hope you have a great day
a great year
and you will be a great mother to your
baby boy
bye
[Music]
oh my god
marlon if carlin says i'm gonna be a
great mom then it's facts so for those
who may not be familiar literally a
month ago
i tried to get a cameo from carlin when
jackie was really at the height of her
obsession with carlin and it went
unresponsive and then last night the
cameo gods opened up their clouds and
dropped a cameo
from
carlin
oh my god that is so beautiful you
obviously have to send it to me damn i
haven't seen carlin in a while because
she's they've been in zion so she hasn't
been on the show but look at she's such
a professional queen like hitting all of
her talking points
throwing in a joke
you love to see it
yeah so that really made my night last
night and i'm glad you didn't pick up
the phone when i called because i think
it's better to have shown it to you on
on camera
that is so sweet i feel so like thought
of and i really appreciate the gift you
know i love our sporadic gift exchange
it's been a while since we've done it
and now it's my turn i owe you
that is true you do owe me and i don't
know how you're gonna top a cameo from
the one and only carlin
no that's literally an amazing idea i
don't know how i'm gonna top that with a
gift that you're just gonna leave in the
studio and never take home i know um
also speaking of studio i am at the
studio today which does mean
my tabletop triangle will be making many
appearances
so get ready for lots of song and dance
today y'all
i'm so excited it also means that you
are filming an interview with a guest
yes so i'm in studio because i'm filming
an episode today that will air tomorrow
with our we'll do a regular episode
excuse me so it's a guest segment yeah
to get a second we'll do a regular
episode tomorrow and then at the end i'm
sitting down with someone who's been
highly
requested on this show um and someone
who i've actually never met but i've
spoken to like a bunch of times so i'm
actually excited to meet them in person
and it's gonna be really exciting
yeah i mean i'm so excited as a fan to
watch the two as a fan of both of you
actually just to watch like two people
who i enjoy converse it's something that
i would watch on my own if i wasn't a
participant in this show um and no
pressure but like
you gotta crush it no i know
um and we also just have like a great
show today because there's obviously the
fast five it's dear toasters which is
always a great day
and did you watch summer house i did i
caught up on summer house last night i'm
pretty much all caught up except i i
didn't record the first 20 minutes of
last night's episode so i missed the
response of like are you hooking up with
kristin
so we didn't really get much gap like
craig was being a gaslighter and like
like paige was basically like i know i
can't be mad but like i can be sad
yeah sure but like she's doing the exact
same thing with andrea like literally to
a t and andrea's in the house no and she
knows that but she's i guess she's now
discovering like she actually has real
feelings for craig
totally and i'm excited to talk about it
and so just those 20 minutes i missed
but i watched the rest of the episode
and i watched everything that i had
missed previously so um i'm excited yeah
and i really i just want to get your
take on like everyone like what your
thoughts
yeah i have some strong feelings but i'm
also seeing how like my feelings are
already changing so i don't want to say
anything like too hurtful because i
can't take that back right and then you
and then and i'm really
i don't feel this way about summer house
but i feel this way about housewives
it's like doing this show
it like i sometimes feel like i might
not want to say something about someone
just in case like we ever have them on
you just don't want like your words to
come back to haunt you
and
then i think we need to make a pact like
if either we keep recapping and saying
our truth or
no housewives come on because it's like
you don't want to say something like
later regret
i want paige on
the toes so i had i couldn't think of
one crossword to say about paige oh me
neither literally can you imagine just
like running around in a house full of
cameras looking as snatched as she does
like with her legs in different
positions like i would be so
self-conscious she's so stunning and
also her mom gives such good advice i
was thinking like that is really sound
motherly good dating advice
yeah except she's team andrea and i just
i can't she doesn't know yet she doesn't
know yet
she doesn't know craig like we do but no
i wasn't talking about the summer house
cast like i um
i feel comfortable sharing my my
thoughts and opinions your true thoughts
and most of them are positive but it is
interesting how like people just can
grow on you in one episode and i'm like
oh
i take back everything i said
totally absolutely
so
i guess without further ado because we
have so much to do to do um let's get
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
gem so i have taken supplements for
quite some time and i've found that
either they don't work or they just kind
of make me feel like worse um and that's
why i love gem because nearly 90 of
americans are nutrient deficient there's
a massive misconception that just
because you eat healthy your body
doesn't need anything extra and our food
system today is totally broken even if
you eat a well-rounded diet it's
impossible to get all the nutrition you
need and gem is solving this issue by
filling the gaps in your diet with daily
nutrition in one delicious bite because
gem believes in eating your vitamins
because food can't fit in a pill gem is
made up of a blend of 15 plus whole food
ingredients that give you all the
essential vitamins minerals adaptogens
superfoods prebiotics and probiotics to
address our modern lifestyle needs and
key deficiencies helping with total mind
and body support i have found that since
taking gem i'm really feeling like a lot
of difference in my mindset and my
overall fatigue which has always been a
problem
and that's always what i've turned like
vitamins and supplements for but i
haven't had a lot of success until jam
like i feel a visible difference i don't
have like that three o'clock fog or
crash um and if you want to check out
gem and try their seasonal favorite
citrus ginger daily
um you could try for yourself and we
have a special offer for the morning
toast listeners go to
gemvitamins.com tmt and enter code tmt
at checkout for 30 off your first order
that's gemvitamins.com
tmt for 30 off your first order thank
you jim for sponsoring today's episode
and to stamps.com because time is money
don't waste either with repeated trips
to the post office with stamps.com you
can skip the trip and focus on how to
make your small business to the next
level stamps.com lets you print official
postage right from your computer and
saves you money in the process so you
can spend less time at the post office
and more time making your customers
happy
stamps.com saves you time money and
stress for more than 20 years they've
been an indispensable
additive for over 1 million businesses
so whether you're sending invoices
you're running a side hustle etsy shop
or a full-blown warehouse shipping out
orders stamps.com will make your life
easier all you need is a computer and a
standard printer you're up and running
in minutes printing official postage for
any ladder any letter any package
anywhere you want to send stop
overpaying for shipping with stamps.com
sign up with promo code toast for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial free postage and a digital scale
there's no long-term commitments or
contracts required just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and enter code toast
awesome okay our first story like i
can't believe this is news i feel like
i'm in middle school but it's also a big
deal
pete davidson calls kim kardashian his
girlfriend for the first time
pete davidson was on people the tv show
and when he was asked if his heightened
fame had led to a more fun lifestyle he
simply responded that most of his days
consist of him showing up to a set or
hanging with friends or his quote
girlfriend he said or he ran right by
that word
yep i just either hang with my friends
or chill with my girlfriend inside so i
don't do much i mean
we have to take stock here we have to
zoom out they have been linked since
october it is february like that is a
long time and they're still together and
they're together all the time like duh
their boyfriend and girlfriend
but it's still shook worthy to hear him
say it considering i don't think any of
us thought that we would still be here
five months later
no he and he literally swallowed the
word like i gotta hang out with my
friends my gran um and also there were
two other notable things that happened
from the interview in the background um
the host pointed out was like do you
have a kim kardashian you know those
prayer candles where like
yeah like those long tall candles
kim has one with her face on it and he
had one in his room which was incredibly
cute and then also she was asking him
about valentine's day and he was like
this is like the first year i think i'm
like having a real valentine's day which
is so
cute how was it the first year he always
has a girlfriend
maybe not like in february because he
only he does like brief stints you know
yeah and i'm sure
boyfriend he's one of those guys who
like breaks up before valentine's day so
it's like not to get too serious resumes
after valentine's day but because he's
looking forward to valentine's day with
kim like once again shows that this
relationship is much more mature
than we thought it would be
you know like when it first started i
was like this is perfect thing for kim
you know bounce back have fun but i
don't know the more i learn the more i
think this has otp potential
otp potential you think so
i get i mean i don't know and it seems
like kim is in the best place she's ever
been
anything could happen and pete does have
to you know settle down at some point
with someone
and
maybe it's kim i haven't
i haven't really confronted that thought
yet to me this is still like you know uh
cuffing season fling
and yeah rebounding from however long
she was married but i would love and i
doubt she would love to be wrong here i
welcome that
i doubt she wants to like jump back into
like a commitment
marriage otp but you just never know
like
you expect a rebound and then you just
fall head over heels you just never know
that's a beautiful thing about love
yeah so that's really exciting on the
kim and pete front um
so happy for them
something for the keat stands also our
next story is a little more pete
davidson news completely unrelated but
still exciting
new york city is giving pete davidson
and colin jost extra time to move the
staten island ferry so pete davidson and
colin jose bought okay i don't know if
you know this pete davidson and colin
jost bought a retired staten island
ferry and they want to turn it into a
comedy club
but they're having am i gonna have that
idea
yeah they're having a hard time moving
the ferry and like getting it into por
literal ship at port um but the city is
giving them extra time to figure it out
the massive ship called john f kennedy
was still birthed saturday on city
property near the st george ferry
terminal well past the 10 business days
they were required to move it by however
um the post is told that city hall is
giving them an extension they're working
with us they know it's not an easy task
and they're being very helpful in
helping them get the boat to appear but
then they're gonna start a comedy club
in a retired staten island ferry and i
just think that is
so
cool
no that's a really sick idea i love
people you know obviously pete davidson
is from staten island and i saw people
on tick tock were shook to find out that
colin jost was from staten island as
well maybe because pete talks about it
like 24 7 and colin just has never
mentioned it um
so i guess this is what they were
referring to this is how the internet
found out that colin jost actually was
in fact from staten island i love people
who give back to their community who
want to help their cities new york is in
dire need of some new attractions i
think this is such a cool idea i can
imagine getting like a little nauseous
like you're already nervous you're doing
stand-up for the first time you just got
booked five minutes at the staten island
ferry stomach's in knots you get on
stage the boat doesn't stop moving you
just puke
yeah but you have to think of all of
these like cruise performers and stuff
who perform on
boats all the time plus they're on huge
boats
this is a big [ __ ] vessel like this
is sir this isn't a little you know um
tug boat it's
it's big i'm sure you could feel like
the motion of the ocean beneath you but
i don't think it'll be that crazy it's
like when you go to actually even when
you go to like a restaurant like grand
banks you know that place yeah it's like
a boat
this is so much this is so much bigger
than that
yeah no and people go there willingly
people go there of their own volition so
they do i think it's such a cool idea
yeah me too and just the idea of
thinking about like
pete colin kim scarjo like taking in an
evening of comedy on a retired staten
island ferry is the sort of dreams that
i didn't even know that i had
and you know what this is in from a
business perspective like really a
no-brainer because i can't imagine
they're gonna have a shortage of
comedians who would love to do shows
there i mean
up and comers of course because you want
to be seen by colin jost who writes for
snl and pete davidson but then also like
they have so many comedian friends like
this is going to be a pop-in destination
they want to park it in staten island
no just um appear off the in the city
they need to find like you know uh home
for it but they also need they're having
a harder time moving it from where it is
right now it like is going to cost a lot
of money and a lot of doesn't the boat
just need to like put it into drive
[Laughter]
that wouldn't make sense but it's in the
water and it's a boat
where are the keys
what's so difficult i'm not
understanding put the sail up and go
that is so
so funny it's like broken maybe it's
broken and that's why it's retired
yeah exactly they do have to tow it but
that's that's really a good idea
something we're thinking about
something to think about for sure i mean
who knows maybe this will become like
the premier comedy spot in town and like
you'll be able to see not like other
girls there oh my god i would love to
i would be honored to
humble too
i think this is such a cool idea i'd
like this is so unique i can't think of
anyone doing it's so them cause pete is
so staten island and they're so comedy
and i just think it's great i think it's
going to be giving comedy seller a run
for their money
yeah no and i think there's never enough
comedy and people like love a night out
i think this is just a great idea by all
accounts and i um
i hope i i step foot in there one day
even though i'm probably support
um i wouldn't the one who would get
queasy like that's too much for me but
i'm very i'm very delicate with the
motion of the ocean so i'm not one to go
by but you're so delicate you just make
little small pool rocks
small poop rocks oh my god that was so
[ __ ] funny yesterday if you haven't
listened to yesterday's episode we
hit off our inaugural segment uh no
yeah we launched
okay whatever we have a new segment on
mondays called unburden yourselves and
if you want to submit i just want to
stress the email is unburden yourself
plural not unburdened yourself we
couldn't get that email right and
because of that we're going to make the
name of the segment unburden yourselves
because why do we need to make it so
[ __ ] confusing it's inverting
yourself but the emails and burning
yourselves it's
just the whole thing is called unburden
yourselves
i changed it i realized that yesterday
so i changed it in the description of
the episode because i was like why are
we making our lives more difficult
harder
yeah it ain't right
it ain't right
are you ready for our next story
yeah
okay
cause we are welcoming another queen to
the pregnancy club shea mitchell is
pregnant expecting her second child with
matt babble
she announced that she is pregnant with
her second child and said saying goodbye
to a loved one while simultaneously
experiencing the joy of welcoming
another into this world is the great
cycle of life it is almost my
challenging it is also my most
challenging season to date she said um
her grandmother had passed away last
week so she's you know
these two things are happening at the
same time
emotionally but
we are very excited for her she's so
premium like everything she puts out is
just like gorgeous stunning perfect
this photo shoot she had was
chef's kiss impeccable just like
gorgeousness um
but i love to talk excuse me hold on i
have to sneeze i'm going on mute
oh i love that i can mute myself um
talking about shay mitchell like really
reignites my love for examining the post
life and career of all the pretty little
liars girls like for me and do i talk
about this a lot is this one of my
things
it's not one of your things but it's
like um it's getting there
it's not getting there it's just
i don't know where i would categorize it
but go off you're you're very passionate
i just love i think it's like such an
interesting like hollywood um
what's it called when it's like a test
case case study
on
how four girls can rise to fame and then
they all literally did completely
different things with it afterwards and
i feel like if i had to have been one of
those girls i would have wanted to be
shay mitchell
yeah but which part do you think that
she's excelled at best because she does
a lot yeah but she's i would say
her career is like being like a really
really high profile influencer
yeah she also is a little bit
and she's an entrepreneur she has her um
like she's a cocktail
luggage company
and a canned cocktail
oh wow
yeah she does a little bit of everything
yeah and i think she's like did it
really well like i remember when she was
on pretty little liars especially
towards the end she was just like
plugging her youtube channel so much and
i'm like why are you doing this but you
know long term i think she has such an
interesting like well-rounded career um
that includes acting but it's not the
main
drag
yeah for me i'm more of a lucy hale you
know i would have pivoted towards
hallmark movies and um the cw and
influencing as well also good and then
troy belisario very much went like the
activist route i know she's like a big
um activist especially on social media
and ashley benson just kind of went like
the socialite route like she doesn't
really like do anything but she's still
really famous
yeah and trying like whatever she did
she ended up at the royal wedding and so
she also made it she made a really good
marriage like i think they have a good
marriage i think they love each other
very much and he also got her invited to
the royal wedding and that is truly a
match made in heaven yeah so ever it all
has its pros and cons it all worked out
it did it really did well i'm happy for
shane mitchell another one added to the
club as we as you know the club shrinks
and it grows at the same time we just
kylie's now you know in the post garden
club but now we have shea so it's it's
still exciting though i do feel like
less of a kinship to um
just because i'm like you're almost
there like yeah you're not really at the
club anymore
no i'm in the club it's i'm as clubby as
like
yeah
by the way
i'm doing good i am i can't believe
you're still here
i know i know
struggle is real like for the past month
i've been like mornings are mornings are
my favorite yeah
now
i still love like doing the toast like
once we're into the toast but like just
even getting ready it's not like i'm
sleeping so well but it's like just
having to wake up and then get out of
bed as opposed to like lay there even
though i do need to get up because i do
need to pee it's just like i'm
physically more
exhausted like everything hurts it's so
crazy like i'm just constantly every
time i move a muscle i'm like
like everything comes with a soundtrack
i feel like you've set a really bad
precedent here at the morning toast this
is our first you know maternity leave
and i just feel like you've said a bad
precedent like you should have been gone
months ago
and i just want to say like i will not
be doing what you did that is fine
everyone is different and i
whatever you need to do you'll need to
do that's completely fine and i'm just
doing like whatever i can but i also
know it's nice to know that like you
know you have given me a lot of
flexibility though i have not opted to
take it but i do feel very much um
accommodated here at the morning toast
with our uh
pre and postpartum
uh
policies schedule
yeah good good good
we are a company that supports pregnant
women
we are
we are don't get it twisted
are you ready for our next story which
our fourth and fifth stories actually go
together and they're kind of like iconic
great well maybe it'd be a great time
for me to tell you about noon before we
jump into the duel stories yes please do
all right you guys nume is unlike other
restrictive diets workout programs
because new weight uses psychology to
empower you with practical knowledge and
skills you need to build smarter more
sustainable long-term habits and
behaviors their psychology approach is
based on scientifically proven
principles like cognitive behavioral
therapy which helps people better
understand their relationship with food
and why they eat the way that they do
noob doesn't believe in restricting what
you can or can't eat instead noon will
give you the knowledge and wisdom you
need to make informed choices that not
only fit your lifestyle but also help
you reach your goals because you're the
boss and you decide how new weight fits
into your life not the other way around
5 10 or 15 minutes a day however time
however much time you want to spend on
the app is totally up to you and there's
there's good science behind neum you
guys more than 75 of users have
completed the program i know jackie you
had a lot of success with noob obviously
before you got pregnant
yes i love nume i think it's like the
perfect friend and companion when you
are trying to set goals reach your goals
whatever they might be big or small
sometimes it's just a lifestyle change
sometimes it's just knowing what you're
putting into your body just to like have
a at a glance view of it and new makes
all of that so easy i'm actually
feeling very uh prepared for the next
few months knowing that like i have noom
on my side because they really take a
lot of the guesswork and
the guesswork out of you know trying to
change your lifestyle but also they add
the accountability that can be sometimes
like it's it it's hard enough doing the
work let alone like keeping yourself
accountable so numa is wonderful for
that
sign up for your trial and get
psychology-based support and motivation
to reach your goals at noom
n-o-o-m
dot com toast that's
n-o-o-m dot com slash toast to sign up
for your trial
thank you claudia now our fourth and
fifth stories will go with the fourth
and then the fifth because that's how
you know numbers work
but we have oscar nominations
and we have razzie nominations today
so
i'm ready for number five
i know me too but let's just go through
the oscar nominations also to see if
there's any crossover something that's
nominated for an oscar and razzie that's
always so funny when that happens or
like an actor actress who's nominated in
one movie for an oscar and in another
for
the razzies are so shady like i didn't
know that they released their
nominations the same day as the oscars
like that is
peak comedy
everything about their aziz are iconic
and i think
it's like a dream of ours to host the
razzies more so than the oscars if the
razzies are listening like
we love we love everything that you do
year after year you never disappoint
okay ever so here are the oscar
nominations for the big categories okay
best picture we have belfast coda don't
look up drive my car dune king richard
licorice pizza nightmare alley the power
of the dog west side story
okay a thousand movies
a thousand movies i have not seen one of
them
me neither and what's notably missing is
house of gucci
yes and lady gaga did not get the
nomination either for best actress and i
think you know her fans are quaking but
i haven't seen it yet so i can't say
but
the reviews and the trailer like
didn't look promising anyways let's
continue on
best actress jessica chastain the eyes
of tammy faye olivia coleman the lost
daughter penelope cruz parallel mothers
nicole kidman being the ricardo's
kristen stewart spencer
all right still no house of gucci i
haven't seen any of these movies i love
nicole kidman i love penelope cruz i'm
happy for everyone i've never seen it i
love olivia coleman i hope they all win
oh and kristen stewart this is her first
oscar nomination right
i think so even though she was snubbed
for twilight breaking dawn part part one
and two um i agree i i hope she wins i i
do love her even though i also heard bad
reviews about spencer so
yeah then for best actor we have javier
no not these days javier bardem for
being the ricardo's benedict cumberbatch
the power of the dog andrew garfield
tick tick boom will smith king richard
denzel washington the tragedy of macbeth
um what i heard the only thing i've
heard about any of these films is that
like will smith like put his foot in
king richard like he was incredible so
he's an amazing actor i hope i actually
am rooting for
for will here
yeah then i'm gonna scroll down we don't
need to do like supporting whatever um
just some other categories that i
personally enjoy best animated film i
mean i don't i think it goes without
saying it'll be and kanto but
the nominees are encanto flee
luca the mitchells versus the machines
raya and the last dragon
luca was big
luca was big but like and kanto was
taking the world by storm and i know so
many people message me i know that
there's a song
no no no
wait
[Music]
that's the only part i know because
that's the part that went viral on
tiktok and then this song also went
viral on tech talk
did that the man of my dreams
that's all i know
very cool everyone you don't understand
like is like you have to watch in kanto
there's a song about bruno and i haven't
watched yet and olivia it was like
kayla loves in kanto and olivia's like
you have to watch in kanto like you're
gonna love it plus plus there's the
bruno element but i still haven't
watched it and like i'm sure i'll be
watching in kanto like for the rest of
my life rest of your life i
don't need to watch it right now even
though like it's i think that there's a
song about bruno watch poldark
watch ozark poldark
yeah while i still can even luca there's
a character named bruno silencio bruno
so silence
bruno is on the up no that name is going
to be like next year's top
level names yeah no it's it's iconic i
love
bruce i miss him even though he's in
chile
and then best original song is always a
fun category we have be alive from king
richard by beyonce
dos
from encanto lin-manuel miranda so uh we
don't talk about your notes actually
we don't talk about bruno was not even
nominated um for the for this category
then we have
down to joy from belfast by van morrison
no time to die from no time to die billy
eilish somehow you do from four good
days by diane warren
so obviously there's like a
almo it's almost like a joke now diane
warren is like the leonardo dicaprio of
this category she's nominated every
single year and i do not believe she has
won once um crazy i don't think that
this is her year i do think billy eilish
will win
you think so yeah i feel like
and kanto might win i i honestly i don't
know enough of the songs but like
i don't know i honestly i don't know and
i don't care especially since we don't
talk
we don't talk about bruno um obviously
he should have been the one but they put
forth probably this one instead
well i'm holding on for diane warren
tonight's this year's her year
yeah it seems like as good a year as any
yeah
now lady gaga got nothing
i know
and she like put her whole like life and
foot into house of gucci and now she has
to like do that again for another
picture if she wants to be and she put
her back into it yeah yeah you know she
like just leaves everything like it's
probably exhausting
well she has the oscar from shallow
she has grammys obviously did she get a
tony
no
no
lady gaga egot
singer songwriter has two golden globes
which doesn't count
yeah she got um
those the harper's bizarre like talk
about giving us crap we don't need
sheep i think she has an emmy from
american horror story she does she has
an emmy and a grammy multiple
two golden globes that don't count
obviously a million grammys oscar yes
so she just needs the tony
yeah this is the only initial she has in
touch yet the superstar has not yet
earned a tony nomination but we wouldn't
be surprised if she brought her towns to
the broadway stage in the near future
maybe suggest a theater adaptation of a
star is born harper's bizarre just stick
to the facts okay
no they people have a really hard time
doing that no everyone's got to be like
a comedian you know
yeah totally okay but more importantly
it's time for the razzies are you ready
it's the final razzie
[Music]
dude
[Music]
and that's a magic number
[Music]
thank you wonderful feels good to
express myself
the nominees for worst picture are
diana the musical
infinite
karen
space jam a new legacy and the woman in
the window
i haven't heard of really any of these
you woman in the window is the movie
that was based on the book that's like a
thriller amy adams is in it um
i didn't hear whether it was good or bad
but apparently it was bad and you've
heard of spaceship obviously
yeah i feel like based on the titles
diana the musical should lose should win
yeah okay worst actor scott eastwood
dangerous
that's blasphemous that ain't right
blasphemous
roy heart ramp as prince charles and
diana the musical
i think to adam the musical might sweep
this year lebron james and space jam
ben platt and dear evan hansen
ding ding ding we have a winner
mark wahlberg in infinite
didn't see it i think
i've only seen one of these movies but
ben platt definitely feels like he gave
the worst performance
then we have worst actress
we have
ben platt like takes himself so
seriously like do you think he got like
an email from his manager this morning
that like he got nominated for a razzy
and like it's bothering him i do think
it's bothering him i don't think anyone
told him yet i think they're trying to
figure out how to tell him yeah
delicately
worst actress we have amy adams in the
woman in the window she can't win
jenna dewall diana the musical megan fox
midnight in the switchgrass
taryn manning karen
ruby rose vanquish
a sweep for diana the musical i really
am
wow we're supporting actress amy adams
again for dear evan hansen
and taryn manning again
taran manning they're both nominated in
both categories
wow she was really bad amy adams
she must have been if the razzie said so
this is so funny
so so funny also in worst supporting
actor um ben affleck is nominated for
the last stool jared leto house of gucci
well there's there's house of gucci's
nomination
well
nick cannon the misfits more diana the
musical
crazy i'm pulling for diana this year
uh you are okay you should also watch it
i would rather i'd rather have a day of
watching razzie nominees than oscar
nominees i couldn't agree more so much
more complex and dynamic
a hundred percent
anyways there's some more categories
that are hysterical but may the worst
actors win
congratulations ben platt
to everyone who was nominated like what
is what does hollywood like think of the
razzies because i respect them but like
is it something like it started off as
like a parody but now it's like
something we've all come to look forward
to every year
yeah i think some probably some actors
like lean into it especially if you're
someone who was nominated for an oscar
and a razzie in the same year i don't
think that we have any of that here
but uh
it's it's it's funny like i hope that
they can laugh at themselves
it's hysterical speaking of hysterical
when no today's tuesday tuesday is the
day we do deer toasters which is our
advice segment so if you ever want to
write in it's dear toasters at gmail.com
and we will do our best to guide you you
know
in the best possible route it's totally
anonymous so again that's dear toasters
gmail.com here we go
good morning ladies
here's an important fact i'm 27 and
here's my dilemma i seem to have a type
and that seems to be 20 years older than
me my most recent axes are 45 41 and 47.
i've always found myself dating men who
have daughters close to me in age and
closer to me in age than they are for
the record we've always become besties
and that's never been a problem i really
don't want kids of my own so there's no
issue but i do find myself worried about
30 years from now when i'm still in my
50s and my husband is almost 80 and
needs a diaper change of course my poor
father isn't exactly thrilled when he's
meeting my new man and they're
practically the same age and he made a
comment the other day implying he really
wishes i would find someone younger my
mom seems to have made peace with this
but i'm torn i've recently tried dating
a couple guys in their late 20s early
30s but it lasted like two dates because
i was just not into it i recently
started talking to another guy and of
course he's 43 and of course i'm super
into him for the record i'm young hot
successful i'm financially independent
with a great career and i've purchased
multiple homes completely on my own so
i'm not after their money i'm just into
maturity so do i keep being that girl
who dates old men or do i suck it up and
lower my maximum age on bumble
sincerely a toaster with salt and pepper
taste
i have to say
i think there's two things here
one
i don't think there's anything wrong
with dating someone older especially
you're not like you seem like your your
motives are totally pure but
i hear you on the being 50 and wiping
your 80 year old husband's ass i hear
you so can we date like a 35 year old
like 37 38 someone 10 years older not 20
that way you're closer and they're still
mature
that's what i was thinking too like you
just because like 20 years old is a lot
older than you like doesn't mean you
have to date someone your old age your
own age and i also think i you make a
very good point about like being
attracted to
maturity and so
if you are like having good
relationships i wouldn't worry about
that so much and i also wouldn't worry
about what's going down when you're 50
years old because also when you're 50
like everyone's mature and then maybe
it's time for you to date someone your
own age at that point
so
don't worry about 30 years from now just
do what makes you happy and try and find
the best connection for yourself and
maybe you could you know high 30s it
find some somewhere in the middle but
the heart wants what it wants and it
does sound like you like who you like
you like who you like and your motives
do sound pure and um
maturity is very attractive so
i
i think as long as you can like see like
it seems like you you see all of the
quote-unquote issues and what could
arise and you're not like keeping your
head down or blind to it so
i wouldn't be so worried i mean it
definitely it's probably like a bummer
for your parents um parents but
but when you meet the right person you
bring the right person home like i think
it won't be so difficult to convince
everyone
yeah and i think the fact that you've
come to the realization that you don't
want kids like you're free to do
literally whatever the [ __ ] you want and
i think you should just listen to the
song who you love by john mayer because
it's really like you love who you love
who you love who you love so whoever
you're attracted to that's who you want
to be with it's your life like you got
to be happy
yeah you know yeah
i think it's okay
agreed next up this sounds like a book
though like something colleen hoover
would write you know
that you would read all right hello
that i would read yes claudia and jackie
how you doing i'm seeking advice about a
proposal disclosure my husband's best
friend of many years and the best man in
our wedding has not told us that he got
engaged on new year's eve here's some
context he and my husband were very
close throughout high school and college
we've met his girlfriend several times
over the past three-ish years and we
really like her they recently moved back
to our hometown where we no longer live
so there's some geographical distance
between all of us we saw them over the
summer and the best man told my husband
that he had bought a ring and was
waiting for the right time to propose
well after new year's i was snooping
around on instagram and i saw through
someone else that he had proposed i
thought my husband would like to hear
the news that is from his friend
directly so i didn't say anything
assuming that he would text him within a
few days neither of them are very active
on social media well now it's been a
month i know that if i tell my husband
he'll be hurt that his best friend
didn't tell him himself i don't think
that they've texted in the past month
but they are in a somewhat active group
chat with some other friends so i'm
surprised it hasn't come up should i
just tell him and get it over with so he
can congratulate the couple or do i
continue to wait it out and fake
surprise when he finds out another way
am i wrong to think that this is shady
sincerely the second hand offended wife
okay first of all it is shady but it's
also weird you haven't told your husband
like just tell him yeah just tell him be
like hey i was on social media you see
so-and-so got engaged because also say
when i mean it's weird that you can tell
it's weird that he hasn't
what is that i didn't say that that's
what you just said
you did you were like just say hey
are you okay
jackie you
remind the tapes rewind the tapes you
literally were like
are you you're shielding me is there
someone in the studio who can they can't
hear but you are gaslighting me someone
check on her we'll rewind it
continue you said it hey
okay
i lost my train of thought which is that
it's weird that the friend hasn't told
your husband but they also don't seem
like chatty girly girls like who you
know are up each other's butts all the
time
but um
and i'm sure eventually he'll tell and
then like what are you gonna wait three
months and pretend to be surprised and
like in these three months you knew like
just say to your husband oh my god i saw
on social media so and so got engaged
and then he'll reach out and be like hey
congratulations
i don't think it's that i think you're
applying this
i think you're applying the standards
for female friendship and projecting
them on to like your male friends
your husband's friendship with his dudes
like especially if they're like don't
live near each other it's definitely not
like
super normal that he didn't tell him but
it's not like the craziest thing i think
it's weirder that you didn't tell him
yeah it's not super normal but it's not
the craziest thing and i think you know
you can put this to bed really easily
and in a very uh benign way by just
being like hey i saw this you should
like send him a text honestly you do
sound like a pot stir like trying to
make drama where there's not no you're
looking for stuff you're looking for
drama yeah yeah yeah
you're a stuff
hello have we met
all right third and final dear toasters
again if you've written us in recently
and we've given you sound sage or
terrible advice update us it's not nice
you guys leave us hanging like you take
our good advice and then ride off into
the sunset
hello jackie and claudia first off
congratulations on everything the two of
you have going on jackie you'll be the
most incredible mom to lc and claudia my
friends have told me your show is
hysterical why haven't you come your
friends have told you
maybe it hasn't hit her town yet i'm
writing in because something happened
that i still can't wrap my mind around
and definitely cannot bring it up to my
therapist she'll think i'm insane
i've had a crush on a co-worker of mine
for months the only problem is he's
married i know that's bad but hey i'm
never gonna act on it right so what's
the harm or so i thought
a few weeks back he and i were alone at
a hotel bar on a work trip when things
started to get a little flirty
next thing i know drunk me decides to
tell this man that i think he's hot and
haven't been able to get the thought of
him out of my mind
i assumed he would just laugh it off but
no this man straight face offers a
threesome with him and his wife
i assumed it was just the casamigos
talking so i laughed and changed the
subject the next day it was as if
nothing happened so i just went on with
my life thinking he had forgotten about
that drunken part of our conversation
i was wrong
this morning in the office he pulled me
aside to let me know that his offer
still stands and that his wife loves the
idea
i told him i think about it and get back
to him
do i do it i mean this man is literally
my ultimate crush also how the hell
would someone turn that down without
making things awkward i should also add
to the fact that i've never had a
threesome before not that i'm not
totally open to the idea just no one's
ever offered it up until now
rude let me know and i'll definitely
report back oh yeah if you don't report
back on this one i'll kill you sincerely
i turned on but not wanting to lose my
job toaster
i just want to say one thing
before we give advice
not wanting it to be awkward in the
office is not a reason
not to turn him down like if you don't
want to do it you don't feel comfortable
turn him down
yeah and i i spoiler alert i think it's
gonna be more awkward if you do it and
then go back to the office it's awkward
no matter how you slice it but
at the end of the day do what you want
to do not because you're worried about
anything also you're you're a toaster
who doesn't want to lose your job i i
mean i don't i can't imagine how you
would lose your job over this if you are
if he asks you and you're consenting um
it's up to you i think you should do it
i don't think you should do it i think
you should do it you know what there are
some moments in life where you just have
to unleash it do it for the plot do it
for the story like i think you sound
like a fun-loving cool gal as long as
everyone is consenting and everyone's
been tested and you're being safe you
know what have a little fun she said
she's not opposed to the idea of a
threesome so like try it out life is
about adventure experience do it
no i mean i don't think you should do it
and i can't imagine if i were you like
i'm also extremely like awkward in the
workplace person so i can't imagine like
having a threesome with someone and then
like seeing them around i personally
would have to leave the job so if you
said you know you're looking for other
jobs anyway and like on your way out you
want to do a threesome i i could consent
to that for you
but uh
i think this is
bad news bears i actually have a really
good suggestion um i think you should
tell them that if you're if you do want
to do it i think you should tell me like
i'm really down but i think we should
wait until either one of us is gonna
leave or get a new job until we do it so
be like it's like a tentative yes be
like yes but only when the time comes
for me to leave this job or for you to
leave this job then i think we should do
it because i just don't think we should
like set ourselves up for like awkward
intra-office communications so like it's
a yes but a hold
yes but like people stay at their jobs
for years and then what we're just like
walking around the office knowing we
have like a threesome hanging over our
heads still weird
likely a tessa bailey novel it's a
testament no matter how you slice it
things are awkward now
but do whatever you want i'm just saying
if it were me
i could not do it and continue to like
work with this person no i know let me
say i'm a big talker if it were me i
would literally run and get a new job
and start a new life and join the
witness protection program
but i'm
i'm disassociated from this and i'm just
like hearing like you know what but at
the end of the day none of what we're
saying matters if you want to do it or
if you don't want to do it like you need
to decide that within yourself if this
is something you want to do and if you
do
i like my idea of saying yes but only
once one of us is getting ready to leave
this company because we cannot walk
around every day like knowing what we
know yeah and it sounds to me like you
want to do it but you're just worried
about like the awkwardness that's gonna
happen later and i'm here i'm here as
the awkwardness on your shoulder telling
you don't [ __ ] do it it's not worth
the big cloud of awkwardness that's what
i'm also maybe we can have other
toasters chime in who have had
threesomes like are they awkward is it
something that like is so amazing that
it'll be worth all the awkwardness or
it'll be like something that like wasn't
even that great sexually and then you
have to put up with all the awkwardness
in the office for the rest of your life
well i think i think like that part
could go either way but it's the fact
that like you're sleeping with someone
who you work with which even if you were
two single people like to just sleep
together once and then like go into work
every single day like i would find that
to be really awkward but knowing that
like you slept with someone and like
he's married and there's no like
romantic thing happening here but like
we've seen each other's bits and we've
been extremely intimate like that's just
a lot to like have in the back of your
head while you're trying to type up the
end of your
sales report
no i agree jackie but at the end of the
day like i also think like maybe we're
overthinking this and like sometimes you
just have to be crazy like you know like
crazy and i think that this is one of
those moments
i don't think we're overthinking this i
really i think this is this is big stuff
i think you should do it
i think so but maybe you know maybe i'm
crude maybe i'm wrong no you're not
pretty it's no big deal it's another
tuesday no no you're not being prude
you're being prudent you know like
there's a lot to think about here and i
would love to hear other toasters chime
in on what they think
that's today's podcast title prudence i
agree
i agree i agree with you
i want to hear what other people have to
say and if you've had threesome like we
are honestly ill-equipped to answer
this
so
maybe someone with more experience in
the comments can let us know um so that
was dear toasters thank you to everyone
who bravely wrote in of course we'll be
doing this
after jackie it's back from maternity
leave so that was our final one for a
while but still if anything awkward
happens to you in the next month write
us an email dear toasters gmail.org
and now let's do our tv recap our first
summer house recap because we're both
now finally fully caught up is brought
to you by better help this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp you know we talk
a lot about help on this podcast and
this month we're discussing some of the
stigmas around mental health for example
some people think that you should wait
until things are unbearable to go to
therapy but that's not true therapy is a
tool to utilize before things get worse
and it can help you avoid those lows and
a lot of us have been taught that mental
health shouldn't be a part of normal
life but that's wrong too we take care
of our bodies with the gym the doctor
and nutrition we should be focusing on
our minds just as much and betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
again the morning chose listeners can
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
toast that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash toast
morning chose listeners can get 10 off
with that link i mean i've done therapy
if anyone who's done therapy can tell
you like the value it has on just your
overall day-to-day all these things
you're holding on to like let let better
help help you alleviate some of those
because life is hard enough
so jack okay
i want to hear your um
like rundown of what you think of all
the castmates
okay give me a name
and i'll tell you my thoughts um
kyle and amanda
okay so many thoughts first of all i
they are married now and it seems like
they've like obviously worked out
whatever what was going on while they're
filming but i am just going to try and
go off of what i see on tv and i also
feel like kyle is one of these people
who it's like there's kyle the person
and then there's kyle the reality star
and i'm sure like you know in the months
where they're not filming their
relationship is a lot more stable and
they definitely have their issues still
like any other couple but they the show
is such a big part of their life it's
such a big part of their business and he
like i i can see how he like struggles
to
deal with all of those things so i'm
only commenting on kyle the reality star
okay because that's what i see and
that's what i know but it is painful to
watch not only like is he so wrong in
his mistreatment of amanda who is like
the sweetest most patient person and
like he's [ __ ] up in the past and the
fact that like he's getting impatient
that she's like bringing up her cheating
trauma it's like no no that's part of
the fact that she
stayed with you is that this stays with
her and this is a part of your
relationship
even taking out the cheating if your man
is going
is staying at the bar once everybody
else has left and is not coming home
until 4 a.m and he is so [ __ ] drunk
like cheating or otherwise
that is not fiance behavior this man is
like 40 years old and it's i agree it
like the alcohol is really ruining his
life and his relationship and he can't
even see it and then to come home and
not even be contrite about the fact that
like you're acting like a frat boy but
to put it on her that like she's
overreacting when i actually felt like
she was underreacting i wouldn't have
ever spo like i literally would have
never spoken to him again ever
manipulative
especially after like seeing his
reaction it's not like he came in was
like oh my gosh i'm so sorry like i'm
not going to do it again he made him was
being an [ __ ] like i can't believe
she even puts up with that like she's a
much more patient person than i could be
but she also really loves him and just
walking away from the relationship isn't
really an option for her
unless like it absolutely has to be but
it's it's a last resort it's not
something she's just always like i'm
gonna go
so i have a lot of respect for her but
she also like in these first few
episodes she just seemed so sad like
even when she was crying on her birthday
because she felt like a burden to
everyone and no one wanted to celebrate
her it's like
it's it's weird because being engaged is
like supposed to be the happiest time of
your life but it's actually like the
most stressful it's the worst so like
you see this person they're like you
don't seem happy why are you getting
married but it's like it's just the
worst like three months before your
wedding is just like and i can't imagine
that on top of you know filming the show
like all of the the drinking culture and
like everything that comes along with it
it's a really like toxic environment and
she's not a toxic person so it's just a
lot to navigate my heart goes out to her
but i also can see how like they ended
up together but while i'm watching it
right now i'm like girl leave like but
also their business is tied together
it's not that simple yeah
yeah so um okay paige and sierra
queens queens queens queens queens looks
friendship and squiggles queens
positivity
like
the two of yeah there i couldn't say a
bad word if i wanted to
um
i just i love their friendship i love
their style i they're both like they
stay like above the drama but they're
both interesting and i like that like
they're both single and ready ready
ready and willing and able to mingle
they are a joy to watch
um danielle and lindsay
i'll start with lindsay because
everything that lindsay does is then
followed by danielle
um literally
lindsay is someone who like i don't
don't feel like would be my type of
person because she's very like
she's a lot
she has claire crawley chaotic energy
she really really does but she also has
like it seems um
like a very big heart and she can be
like a softy and i feel like she tries
to especially this season i don't know
what she's like what her overall story
is but like this season you know knowing
that uh last month she had a miscarriage
it's like she um
obviously leads with like just being fun
and like i'll deal with that when it's
time to deal with it but you can tell
there's like a sadness there and
i just like my heart i want her to find
happiness and joy but just like being
like you know i'm gonna go to mexico
this week and we're gonna go see the
greek next it's just a lot and she's not
like my kind of
person in general but i have i'm warming
up to her
very quickly yeah so i've like
i've watched
last season and then like sporadically
since the beginning
and
i didn't like her in the beginning and
she's grown on me so much she's she's
definitely a you know unique not
everyone's cup of tea gal but she's just
like a fun loving queen and for the most
part she's like a good friend to
everyone and i actually really like her
now um but it did take me a little to
get used to she's just like she's really
not like other girls i don't i don't
know who i would compare her to she's
different so she takes a little bit and
now knowing that her and carl are like
so in love makes me so happy for both of
them
and carl i just want to say is like a
king and i've actually seen like past
seasons where he's been like the [ __ ]
boy
and like really awful behavior and it's
just like sobriety is so attractive on
on people most people like and i'm just
him like having his morning meditation
and his run and like aaa meetings and
being sober is actually like i think a
really good foil to the rest of the show
that it can be a lot to watch
all of the drinking
there's so much alcohol consumption and
it's like and then you forget and it
always reminds me of jersey shore where
it's like that's what i was just gonna
say
the chemical
the chemical effects of alcohol like
it's a lot like the moral hangover the
anxiety that comes along with it the
things that you do that like you
wouldn't have normally done and i do
think that like i'm sure
you know the idea of being sober on a
show about drinking isn't like doesn't
sound like the best idea but i think it
it
adds like an uh very valid
balance exactly to the show and he to me
is like the most attractive
one of them all i mean they're all so
attractive but now wait go back you
didn't you skipped danielle
i skipped danielle sorry okay i was
trying to avoid like i'm just
i'm not here i'm not enjoying i'm not
receiving what she's giving me no and
she just like follows lindsay around and
she also is in love with kyle i don't
know if anybody has realized said that
okay i know when like the last time i
recap summer house you weren't listening
cause like you don't watch the show i
literally said like she's such a pick me
like all the girls are like fawning over
amanda like oh my god are you okay are
you gonna get married you have this
piece of paper like there's a lot of
real [ __ ] going on and she's like
hugging kyle at the pool like it's weird
yeah it's weird and then also like even
in the way she was talking about amanda
like at the july 4th party amanda was
like you know living her best life
dancing whatever and she was like
talking about her in a way that was like
very backhanded you know like uh jealous
yeah like just trying to make her like
look bad but also while not being
explicitly [ __ ] about talking about
her it was just i think that she is in
love with kyle and also the stuff like
of her relationship it's so funny when
people are like
i mean i guess everybody does this but
she's like we're getting married he's
the one you know we've been together a
year we're living together things are
perfect amazing like couldn't be better
this is forever he shows up and
immediately they're fighting literally
even though
you can't get along for two seconds
robert is a p john like we were
introduced to him last season he's such
like a team player all the guys love him
he comes as much as he can cooks for
everyone he's a sweetie like he's a pee
job so like
if they're fighting like i have to
assume it's denial's fault
oh that's so interesting because i was
just gonna assume like i don't know
robert from adam so i was just gonna
assume like robert's not being there for
her in the way that she needs him to be
but that's no but very good as far as i
know like he's a p john
okay very very good to know and other
than that she's just like up lindsay's
but she's just always up someone's butt
and it's like it's like boring
yeah agreed um i want to talk about maya
because there's she's kind of like
falling through the cracks but i do feel
like there's a lot there and i think
that she's becoming friendly with sierra
and uh paige but she does like talk to
the group next week and start crying and
i don't know what she's talking about
but i kind of feel like she feels like
an outsider like i don't think anyone
has really made like an enormous effort
to get to know her or include her and
then like the final show was when
lindsay was like you can't come
yeah oh my god
why wouldn't you come danielle has a
boyfriend maya doesn't two single girls
going out on a saturday night in the
hamptons one thousand percent and where
are you going that you can bring one
person but you can't bring two people
you went to a car jackie they went to
the they went to the place where they
were at during the day because lindsay
was going to see the bartender and he
was working all night she was like i
promise i'll come back here so it's a
public venue
got it i missed the first 20 minutes so
i missed it i thought maybe she was
going to like some house party or
whatever no they went to a pool party um
it was like looked so pathetic and
because they they're really not allowed
to film at a lot of places so this place
that they went to i've actually been
there before it's like a restaurant it's
a hotel and they go they they go to the
restaurant they keep reciting it's like
different places where is it what is it
i think it's i know one of the
restaurants is some cause it's called
something with a sea i just ate there
this summer um it's like random in
southampton um but they have like a pool
party and they had like a violinist it
was like very low energy and you could
tell nobody was having a good time um
but so they were there during the day
for a pool party then they left and had
dinner at home that maya cooked that
looked so good
and then lindsay went back because she
had been flirting with the bartender and
she promised him she would come back and
so she brought danielle who has a
boyfriend and why why can't you bring
two people to literally a club a public
venue a completely agreed now thank you
for that context yes i had a lot of
thoughts about maya because in the
beginning it was like she was slipping
through the cracks but then i was
starting to feel like everyone on the
show you know has been even if they came
on last season or the season before like
they're very much a part of the cast to
bring on like one new person i guess
that other guy is new to him well it's
happening with both of them like the
guys yeah but he hasn't seen one person
talk to him
okay with it it's like he has really
sheltered himself with like his turkey
and his protein and his food shaming
like what the [ __ ] was that no that's a
whole nother conversation but i was
actually thinking like it must be really
hard to come onto a show like this as
just a completely new person and have to
forge connections with everyone when
everybody's already connected and
they're not as pr like they don't have
it as a priority for them to like get to
know you and i feel like she's actually
doing a really good job like she'll she
went to the brewery with that like that
random random group of people who aren't
even the friends that she came with and
i i feel like even as a viewer every
week we're getting to know her more and
i'm really liking her personality but
like this is it's a very taxing like
social experiment to come into a house
in general like a share house like this
not filmed is a lot filmed is a lot to
come in with people who are all like
celebrities now and best friends and
like is
so much so i think she's doing a great
job but i think she's having a hard time
and if she weren't having a hard time i
that would be surprising so i think
that's what she like sits the group down
i think maybe she wants to leave and
then they keep her and then she ends up
being like a lifelong sister i don't
know but i think that's
i think that has to be what she's
talking about because when lindsay was
just so rude like can i come no like
excuse me
so hurtful so hurtful um and then
there's the andrea craig and paige of it
all obviously craig and paige are so otp
andrea is cute and i know he likes paige
and i think he has good intentions but
it's just not their time
agreed and i mean watching craig and
paige roll out it's definitely like it's
not as seamless as i thought it was not
a fairy tale
and
but i mean that's real life so that's
fine but it really is so interesting and
how paige like just wants to like be
single
and it just has this like idea and
that's always what happens it's like i'm
gonna be single for a year but like what
about what if the love comes at you at
eight months you know i know but thank
you you're liking about it i need four
more months
i'm thinking think about it your page
you got famous like two three years ago
like it's really fresh you're so
stunning you're literally like an
eligible bachelor at socialite of new
york would you want to settle down no
you'd want to have fun for like a few
years and then ultimately settle down so
i just don't think she was expecting
this great love so soon after her most
recent breakup
yeah i guess i would love to know like
more about her dating life in general
and also it's like when she's singles
during this time is she really only
seeing
craig and andrea or are there other
people maybe there are people who are
like even more
eligible interesting famous than craig
is even the thing is i love craig
and i can't tell if paige is only mad
that he's hooking up with someone
because she's famous
and isn't it interesting how they cut
cavalieri out of the whole thing they
just keep calling claudius okay so for
the first two episodes i was like oh
some girl named kristen from uh
charleston is in a triangle like i i
didn't put it together for so long no i
just thought it was like a random girl
like
random random then i put it together
that it was kristin cavallari and i was
so shook and
it brings well first of all so
the question is this whole time that
they were all hanging out and like being
friends and weird like
which one of them was she hooking up
with if either and now the answer is
craig
is it yeah
okay but then that's so crazy because of
the whole madison lacroix jay cutler
thing it's like that was a nothing
burger then they weren't it wasn't even
about austin
no so i when all those rumors were
swirling and they were all like weirdly
hanging out i just assumed it was austin
hooking up with kristen cavallari
yeah and we all did but that
and that's why like last week's episode
was such a bombshell because lindsay was
the one who got it out of craig no it
was actually craig the whole time
but okay i
i was when i was looking for articles
this morning i saw page six where um
amanda batula like did an interview
where she like alluded to the fact that
there's a chance that craig is like
lying about hooking up with kristin
yeah just to make paige jealous
yeah
like so that's a possibility
craig is very charming like he's not
conventionally like
what everyone like he's just like
different and he's like kind of nerdy i
could see him being by the way i'm
sitting right now with my sewing down
south pillows um i could see like him
pulling chris and cavallari i could
no me too but it's like i did he or
didn't he and now if he's like lied
about it that's also weird uh
it's a very interesting dynamic and also
when paige was like it's not i think if
it was any other like random girl like
she doesn't know she doesn't care but
the fact that like now she's in this
public love triangle and it's like
kristin
it's just who wants that
but then when paige is like you put me
in this love triangle i didn't want to
be and it's like pedro eddie was in a
love triangle herself with andre and
craig so it's really like
it's a mirror image honestly except for
that andrea's in the house with them
and like she's like canoodling with him
every weekend
but that's why you can't just like
when she said that it's her idea when
she said
when she said if andrea finds out about
craig like that's not my problem no it's
literally only your problem
yours and yours only and now it's
becoming a problem and you can you can't
avoid like these things
whatever it's nice to know that they
become a couple soon because they go to
paige and a man not paige amanda and
kyle's wedding like as
dates
yeah
but then in last night's episode like
paige
hooks up with andrea
yeah which like was dumb but i get the
point she was trying to make
yeah she's fed up
yeah but like i just feel salt like i
don't even need to like nitpick this
whole thing like i feel peace knowing
that they end up together like no matter
how they get there like i honestly don't
care
yeah no they are so stinking cute i just
i want more of the love and less of the
drama because
i mean my ship is just
so it's a good show right
yeah it is really good and the um the
cast of characters
are good the house and the kitchen is so
nice and uh like they keep it nice and
clean and i saw the inside of the fridge
and it didn't worry me even though alex
and all of his man meets are like coming
through
he and they obviously they go back to
the city every sunday and they have a
cleaning service come to the house so
they can only make it so disgusting
every three days
yeah no so that works for me and just
like this man's commitment to fitness
like it is his like relationship and he
has no time for anything else and he's
to have he's kind of a worse or not yeah
no he's got to loosen up he's like
married to the fitness life and you've
got like
how do you go on a date with someone
even if you're like worried about
getting two
12 terms of protein you know like yeah
100
so honestly i just now my mindset is
like i'm worried about paging craig and
i'm worried about maya like i really
want
her like i do feel bad for her it's a
hard dynamic and i just want her to like
be happy because she seems like a really
nice cute girl
yeah so i'm curious to see what next
week is about uh
and hopefully
hopefully they end on a good note and we
get more paige and craig he needs like
he just should be on the cast i can't
deal with like what weekend is craig
coming i need to be there every weekend
a hug
it's really crazy to see him like
out of his out like
we said this about winter house too but
like i feel like on southern charm he's
always the butt of the joke it's like
craig but now like craig comes to the
hamptons and it's like oh my god craig's
here like she's a big movie star
everything's coming up craig
everything's always been coming up craig
like lest we never forget that craig has
consistently been on the right side of
history on southern charm and i'm so
glad that he's getting his just desserts
and the justice that like he's been
seeking now that he's able like we're
able to see him on a show
where he's able to thrive and not be
under like shep and whitney's boot 100
also it just like shocks me when i think
back to like naomi and craig
and how dearly i shipped
and now like naomi is on southern charm
again and they are filming or they just
wrapped it they've been filming naomi's
there like paige goes down like nao i i
could see naomi and paige like being
friends and i don't think naomi like
whatever
no page on watch weapons live said that
like while they're not like friends they
follow each other on instagram and like
paige thinks she's really cute they're
not like but this was this was like a
couple months ago so maybe since then
they've gotten close
yeah it's just like it's just so crazy
how things change yeah
you know so we'll be adding summer house
to our weekly recaps and tonight we've
got the real housewives of new jersey
second episode of the season and it's
just gonna be a fabulous time full of
fabulous things and we're fabulous girls
and this was a fabulous episode thank
you so much for listening to the morning
show the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast factories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places so every
listen to podcast find us morning toast
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing day happy
tuesday and we'll see you tomorrow for
hump day
[Music]
goodbye